- [Narrator] These days you can learn
practically anything from the internet.
(xylophone chimes)
So the concept of being an apprentice
craftsman may seem a little old school.
But here in the countryside
of Kōchi, Japan,
there is a small blacksmith workshop,
where the apprenticeship style of learning
has not completely disappeared.
(upbeat music)
These blades are called
Nata, and they are used
by professional woodcutters here in Kōchi,
which is a heavily forested
region of the country.
They are the tool chiefly
made by this master craftsman.
But three years ago,
after nearly a lifetime
of working alone, Matsumura
was joined by a young man.
(laughing)
When he learned about
Matsumura, Kikuchi left
his manufacturing job in the city
and approached the aging master
who was hesitant to take on
the young man as an apprentice.
And for Kikuchi, it's
not only about learning
from his master, but learning
how to think like his master.
(upbeat music)